this is the fourth of the five problems
that cortaggio sent me today and i've
been doing these problems because i
think they're really neat applications
of essentially fairly basic uh even you
could call them call it physics rate
problems and a little bit of algebra but
they you're able to figure out pretty
neat things where you're not sure if
there's enough information at first so
here we have train a represented by
these two dots in arrow is 200 meters
long and they did this because i think
they want to be specific about the
configurations they're talking to later
in the problem so let's just read it
train a is 200 meters long train b
is 400 meters long they run on parallel
tracks at constant speeds
when moving in the same direction a
passes b in 15 seconds from so these are
the configurations from a is right
behind b to a is right in front of me so
let me draw that so train a i'll do in
this blue color
so train a is like that and it's 200
meters long
and then train b i'll do in this green
color
train b is double the length so it's 400
meters
and so this is the starting
configuration that they outlined right
here and it says it takes 15 seconds to
pass it to go to this configuration so
the ending configuration looks like this
the ending configuration train b here
and then train a has passed train b
meters this is once again this is 400
meters here and this situation takes 15
seconds
so this takes 15 seconds to happen
15 seconds
so a passes b in 15 seconds so that's
this whole sentence right here
is this right here we go from this
situation to that situation and then in
opposite directions they pass each other
in five seconds so from this
configuration to that so let me draw
that so in the opposite direction
example
they start like this train a is 200
meters
train b
is facing in the other direction
i drew it probably a little bit too long
400 meters
and then in five seconds they get from
this configuration to
this configuration
to that configuration right there 200
and of course this right here is 400
and this takes
this right here takes five seconds so in
opposite directions they pass each other
in five seconds now their question is
how fast is each train moving in meters
per second so once again they gave us
they didn't really give us a lot of
velocity information they just tell us
how long it takes to pass but maybe
using both of these pieces of
information we can solve
so let's say that well you have velocity
of train a
so va
velocity of train a and then of course
you have the velocity of train b
and regardless of which direction
they're facing it assumes that they're
always going at the same velocity so in
this situation and we always have to
remember distance is equal to rate times
time
so relative if we assume because when
you take velocity you can always take a
velocity relative to something else so
first of all relative to train
to this train right here to train b how
far does train a travel well it goes
from this point
it goes from right here
to not just 400 meters it gets to the
point where the front of its where the
front of the train is out here
so it goes it travels has to travel 400
meters and then another 200 meters so it
travels 600 meters
it travels 600 meters in this situation
and how far did it try out does it
travel in this situation well once again
if we assume that this train is
stationary let's and that's i guess the
key assumption we have to make we're
going to do everything relative we're
going to assume that even though it is
moving at a velocity we're going to the
position we're going to make it relative
so relative to this train we move from
right here
to
remove 400 meters and then we move 200
more so again in both situations we move
600 meters in this situation we move 600
meters relative i guess you could say we
move 600 meters relative to the back of
train b in this situation and we move
600 meters relative to the front of
train b in this situation in this
situation we do it in 15 seconds that's
because we're kind of where the velocity
of train a is kind of being eaten away
by the velocity of b right if the
velocity of b was zero if this green
train was really stationary then we'd be
moving relative to this train with
velocity a but now this is going it's
moving at some velocity so
our relative velocity to this train is
going to be something lower and what is
the relative velocity
if you're a passenger sitting in train b
if you're a passenger sitting in train
b's right there how fast will it look
like train a is going what will be the
relative velocity what's going to be the
difference between the two
right
so it's going to be
va minus vb
if you're if you're sitting in this
train right there
and you would say
it takes 15 seconds so rate times time
times 15 seconds is equal to a distance
that it traveled and once again if
you're a passenger sitting in this green
train right here you would say okay it
went from this point it crossed this
entire train and then it went another
200 meters so it went 600 meters
now and this is of course in seconds now
obviously both of these trains if this
has some positive velocity this train
would have moved even more than 600
meters if this train moved 100 meters
and this train would have moved 700
meters but i'm doing everything relative
to what this passenger in the green
train sees
likewise the passenger in the green
train here
let's say the passenger in the green
train right here
oh i drew his arms coming out of his
head but what velocity does he see this
this this the blue train coming in at
well he's going in this direction at 400
meters per second the other train is
coming in no sorry he's going at this
this direction
velocity of train b we don't know what
that is 400 is how long it is
and this train is coming with velocity i
want to do it in blue
with velocity a
so you would add the two velocities if
this is coming at 60 miles per hour and
this is going in that direction 60 miles
per hour to this guy who's stationary in
train b
he would just feel like this train is
approaching him at 120 miles per hour or
the addition of those two so from this
guy's point of view this train
is approaching with the velocity let me
do is approaching with the velocity va
plus vb
vb
and in five seconds and that they give
us that information in five seconds so
velocity times time or rate times time
is equal to distance it travels 600
meters remember this is all relative to
the guy or the gal sitting on this green
train and that's kind of the key
assumption you have to make to make this
problem solvable well now we have two
equations and two unknowns we should be
able to solve this for the velocity of
the two trains
so just to simplify it let's divide both
sides of this one by 15.
so we have the velocity of a minus the
velocity of b is equal to
meters per second
right 60 divided by 15 is 4 yep 40. and
then here we have the velocity of a
plus the velocity of b that's an a
is equal to 120 meters per second
and see we could just take this equation
put it down here we could add the two
equations to each other so the velocity
of a
minus the velocity of b is equal to 40
meters per second
add the two equations
we get 2 times the velocity of a these
two cancel out
is equal to 160 meters per second or the
velocity of a is equal to 80 meters per
second
and then we can just back substitute
here the difference between the two is
40. so let's see 80
minus the velocity of b is equal to 40
meters per second so what's the velocity
of b
well you could just well you could
subtract 80 from both sides you get
minus velocity of b is equal to minus 40
or the velocity of b is equal to 40
meters per second and we've done the
problem and the key assumption there is
to do everything relative to the green
guy
sitting inside of train b you could have
done it the other way you could have
said you could have picked other
relative positions but that's to my in
my brain it was the easiest way to
figure it out so this guy in this case
is going this speed at 40 meters per
second
and this guy is going at 80 meters per
second in this situation this guy is
traveling at 80 meters per second and
this guy's going in this direction at 40
meters per second anyway thanks again to
cortagio for that problem